d'un élément qui est connue est connue
de tous dans le dossier des enquêteurs
du juge d'instruction des avocats depuis
de nombreux mois et qui n'a posé à ce
jour strictement aucune difficulté on
sait tous qu'un cheveu ça peut se
transformer que elle a effectivement pu
monter dans la voiture de travail de son
fils est un point sur lequel il faudra
revenir mais que le fait qu'un cheveu se
retrouve dans une voiture sur un siège
puis ensuite se transporte dans un
véhicule ça ne pose aucune difficulté
il faut savoir qu'à ce jour et c'est
toujours le cas
la maman de john athènes n'a jamais été
soupçonné de rien elle a été entendu à
titre de simples renseignements et je
trouve désagréable que d'abord la lettre
de monsieur grégory gay soit parvenu au
journal le nouvel observateur en
parallèle de son attention directement
juge d'instruction c'est assez étonnant
comme procédé de deux j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que monsieur
grégory et est partie civile dans ce
dossier qu'il n'est pas enquêteurs et
qui n'est pas juge d'instruction ni
procureur de la république je pense que
chacun doit rester à sa place et je
trouve aujourd'hui son intervention
assez étrange pour le moins certains
commentateurs les parties civiles
également estime que cet élément relance
la thèse d'une complicité que veulent
les parties civiles
est-ce qu'elle la vérité ou est ce
qu'elles veulent imposer leur vérité on
a subi la communication des expertises
psychiatriques dans la presse qui était
défavorable johnattan on a subi la
communication de ces documents
informatiques on va pas tout subir
jusqu'à la fin je trouve totalement
anormal la façon dont les parties
civiles viennent de procéder avec cet
élément là qui est annoncé comme étant
un élément nouveau
or ce n'est pas un élément nouveau c'est
totalement erroné